The only thing worse than being a third wheel to a romantic relationship,
is being a third wheel to two best friends.
I've recently introduced two of my friends and it did not go the way that I thought it would.
Heeey!
Hey Gaby!
Meet Allison, Allison meet Gaby!
[Sensual music]
Uh, guys?
Gu.. Guys, do you still wanna... Okay...
And if you're wondering, I thought it would go like this.
Gaby, meet Allison, Allison, meet Gaby.
Hi! Nice to meet you.
Hey!
I like your shirt.
Thanks!
I am the glue that holds us all together.
But no!
They met and it was instafriendship.
Which was great,
until I realized that our whole dynamic was changing.
Soon, I was gonna be the third wheel, while they're
finishing each
other's sentences!
Oh my god!
[Laughter]
The friendship third wheel is its own special kind of loneliness.
It's a horror I would not wish on anyone.
It's a FOMO when yo' sittin' right there tho'.
[Laughter]
What are you guys laughing about?
Gaby said the stupidest thing in this video that she like kept saying and it's so funny.
Can I, can I watch the video?
Oh, don't even worry about it, it's so stupid.
It's honestly the dumbest.
Oh it's like, it's not even worth it. It's like you'd have to see so many...
It's dumb, it's really dumb.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
You'd have to be a fucking idiot not to find it on your own.
[Laughter]
And I felt pretty petty and I felt dumb about how jealous I was.
So I tried to strengthen my bond with them.
Hey! What's up?
Hey! Did you want to watch a movie on Friday?
Ah... Allison and I have plans Friday...
Oh...
Okay then... Um...
How about Saturday?
Yeah sure! I'm free Saturday!
Are you free Saturday Allison?
I'm free! Would love to hang!
Wha... Uh
What time? Probably at night, right? Because we have that...
Yeah, we're busy all day.
Yeah, we have that mic...
And it got to a point where I just had to tell them about how insecure I felt
and how threatened I was by their friendship.
So, I sat them down and I talked to them like the adult that I am.
[Crying]
Oh no! We love you!
You're just between us!
Yeah.
You're gonna be okay, we're all friends.
So I think we can all agree that the moral of this story is...
Never introduce your friends to eachother!
They're yours, yours alone! Never share them with anyone.
I'm Anna Akana, stay awesome Gotham.
[Sensual music] I wanna say thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode.
All of the sites look professionally designed, regardless of your skill level.
And the tools are so intuitive and easy to use.
There's no coding required.
And, if you sign up for a year they give you a free domain.
You can start your free trial at squarespace.com today.
And don't forget to use the offer code Anna for 10% off that checkout.
Squarespace.
I love you.